I'm Jamz Supernova
and I'm a DJ and broadcaster.
And I'm gonna be speaking
to you about the DIY generation.
My generation
and the generation after
are the ones that are
doing it for ourselves.
We're taking control
of our own careers and futures.
So the financial crash
happened 10 years ago
when I was actually in college,
and I remember there was
such an uncertainty in the air
and even the teachers
they were scared for our futures.
A few years after that,
university tuition fees went up
and more recently, zero-hour
contracts have been introduced.
And for some people,
living on a zero-hours contract
just isn't good enough
for them to survive.
So I've felt that our generation have
had to be the hustler generation.
We've had to make things our own
and build our own careers and decide
how much money we want to earn.
And I think that's where
that hustler mentality comes
and I think we're definitely
the hustler generation.
Social media has also played
a massive part in the DIY generation.
Literally if you have a phone
anyone can have a business
if they have a social media account,
you can do it from your bedroom.
It's given anyone a voice now.
It's cut out the middle man or woman.
And it's changed the job market,
I really think the internet
has driven a massive change.
So I've definitely benefitted
from the internet.
I started my journey on Soundcloud
and I would upload radio
shows every single week
to my Soundcloud account.
And Soundcloud, for those
that don't know,
is a music platform which
lets you upload content,
so music content whether it's
productions, remixes or mixes itself.
You can make money through streaming
by putting your music or distributing
your music onto Spotify
or Apple Music or Beatport.
So artists are doing that now,
they're also making
money from live shows.
And by building their following
on Soundcloud
they were able to get live shows
and bookings.
The whole game has changed, I feel
like now the artist is in control.
And they're the ones that have got
the power and can say,
"No, I don’t think I want
a contract like that "
or, "Actually, you might have
to give me that, I'm independent"
There's been an incredible
rise of young people
running businesses just
using their social media accounts
or using the social media accounts
to propel their businesses.
For example, you have
someone like Vicky Grout,
so she's a photographer
and she came up shooting
up-and-coming grime acts
and her portfolio was her Instagram
and that's what was used
to build a following
but then also to get other work.
So now she does incredible campaigns,
people like Nike or
front cover shoots of artists.
It's amazing to see how she's grown.
And then you've also got people
like poets, like Charly Cox
She decided to write a poem
a day for a month,
showcase it on Instagram
and by the end of the month
she had an agent and a book deal.
So this kind of online culture
is really challenging nepotism,
you can get headhunted just
from your online portfolio alone,
whether it's Instagram, whether
it's Twitter, whether it's YouTube.
And I think this definitely
challenges some of the old ways
in which we thought
we had to get jobs.
And this kind of change
is making us more creative.
Take, for example, gal-dem
so they run an online magazine,
for women of colour
by women of colour.
And they created it because they
weren't seeing themselves reflected
in mainstream media.
There's also the noticeable
generation gap,
so the things that my generation
and the younger generation
place value on
is very different to what our
older generation did or does.
They place value on nine to five,
getting a secure job,
getting a pension.
I definitely think that we are
definitely more risk-takers
and we go against the status quo.
I think the things that we place
value on comes down to happiness,
a creative outlet and expression.
So, we spoke a lot about the
great things about DIY generation
but, of course, with everything there
are gonna be downsides as well.
Not everyone has
the financial backing
to get them through dry spells,
not everyone has the luxury
to be able to focus
on their dream full-time.
I think they're the downsides
that we don’t often talk about.
And there are lonely times as well,
imagine you miss
birthdays, christenings.
And that can sometimes result
in the breakdown of relationships
because you are so one-track minded
on your dreams, on your goals
and what you need to do.
But that's also a positive
and I think it's a common trait.
We're persistent as well
so I was told for five years,
"No, you're not good enough for radio
show, not yet, not yet, not yet."
And I just carried on knocking
and eventually got my own radio show.
The DIY generation
fever is spreading,
even the older generation
are starting to think more like us,
with people working multiple jobs,
having side hustles,
creating their
own businesses as well.
And I think it's going to be really
exciting to see what happens
with the younger generation,
and with the faster internet,
the better apps, the better phones,
to see what they can create,
and what they can do.
I think that the world will
definitely be their oyster.